do you have advice for young people
about career about life people in high
school people in college
of um how to live a life they can be
proud of
so I what I like to do is tell people
don't plan it because I didn't plan
anything everything I did was one step
at a time you don't have to plan I just
found things that were interesting to me
and so I my father was a doctor and
he wanted me to be a doctor but I was
not interested in taking care of people
I learned that
but I couldn't say no to him so you know
I was a biology major in college and I I
graduated and um I didn't have anything
to do so I liked science so I got a job
in a lab
and it was very exciting and that led to
everything else that I've done one step
at a time and I think
the most important thing you can do
other two important things you could be
really curious all the time you
mentioned curiosity I think curiosity is
essential
you have to be curious about everything
and if you are you're never going to be
bored yeah and so people who say they're
bored I say you are not curious you
should just think about things and say
look at something and say how does that
work or what what is it doing and how do
they get there and you'll never be bored
and the other thing is when you find
something
which may take time it's fine
um you have to be passionate about it
you have to put everything into it and
that's what I did with viruses so I I
think they're amazing and I tell my
classes
I love viruses they're amazing and
people think I'm morbid because
obviously they kill it they kill people
and I shouldn't love something that but
that's not the point that's not what I
mean I love them in the way they have
emerged and how they work and and so
forth and all that we don't know about
them so you need to be curious and
passionate and don't plan too much and
just find something that you don't call
a job
[Music]
because someone said on the live stream
last week I wish I had a job I I liked
as much as you I said it's not a job I
never looked at it as a job it's my
vocation it's my passion
if it's a job then you're not going to
like it yeah something that doesn't feel
like a job